okay we're going to talk about
statistical learning and and models now
i'm going to tell you
what what models are good for how we use
them and what are some of the issues
involved
okay so we see three plots in front of
us
these are sales figures from a marketing
campaign
as a function of amount
spent on tv ads radio ads and newspaper
ads
and you can see the
at least in the first two is a somewhat
of a trend
and in fact we've we've summarized the
trend by a
little linear regression line in each
and so we see that there's some
relationship the first two again look
uh stronger than than the third
now in a situation like this we
typically like to know
the joint relationship
between
the response sales and all three of
these together
you know we want to understand how they
operate together to influence sales
so you can think of that as as
wanting to
model sales as a as a function
of tv radio and newspaper all jointly
together so how do we do that
so before we we get into the details
let's set up some notation so yes sales
is the response or the target that we
wish to predict or model
and
we usually refer to it as as y we use
the letter y to refer to it
tv is a is one of the features or inputs
or predictors and we'll call it x1
likewise
radio
is x2 and so on
so in this case we've got three
predictors and we can refer to them
collectively by a vector
as
x equal to with three components x1 x2
and x3 and vectors we generally think of
as column vectors
and so that's a little bit of notation
and so now in this more compact notation
we can write our model as
y equals function of x
plus error
okay and this error
um is just a catch all to it captures
the measurement errors maybe in y and
other discrepancies our function of x is
never going to model y perfectly so
there's going to be a lot of things we
can't capture with the function and
that's caught up in the error
and again
f of x here
is now a function of this vector x which
has these three arguments
three components
so what is what is the function f of x
good for
so with a good f we can make predictions
of y at new points x equals little x so
this notation capital x equals little x
you know capital x we think is the
variable having these three components
and little x is an instance also with
three components
particular values
for
newspaper radio and tv
with the model we can understand which
components of x in general it'll have p
components if there's p predictors are
important explaining why and which are
relevant
for example if if we model an income as
a function of demographic variables
seniority and years of education might
have a big impact on income but marital
status typically does not and we'd like
our model to be able to tell us that
and depending on the complexity of f we
may be able to understand how each
component xj affects y in in what
particular fashion it affects y
so models have have many uses and those
are amongst them
okay well what is this function f and is
there an ideal f
so
in the plot
we've got a large sample of points from
a population there's just a single x in
this case and a response y and you can
see there's that's a scatter plot so we
see there's a lot of
point there's 2 000 points here let's
think of this as actually the whole
population or rather as a representation
of a
very large population
and so now let's think of what what a
good function f might be and let's say
not just the whole function but let's
think what value would we like f to have
at say the value of x equals 4 so at
this point over here right we want to
query x
f at all values of x but we wondering
what it should be at the value 4.
so you'll notice that at the x equals 4
there's many values of y but a function
can only take on one value
the function is going to deliver back
one value so what is a good value
well
one good value is to deliver back the
average values of those y's who have x
equal to 4.
and that we write in this sort of mathy
notation over here
it says
the function at the value 4 is the
expected value of y given x equals 4
and that expected value is a just a
fancy word for average it's actually a
conditional average given x equals four
since we can only deliver one value
of the function at x equals four
um the average seems like a good value
and if we do that at each value of x so
at every single value of x we deliver
back the average of the y's that have
that value of x so for example at x
equals 5
again we want to have the average value
in this little conditional slice here
that will trace out this little red
curve that we have here and that's
called the regression function so the
regression function gives you the
conditional expectation of y given x at
each value of x
so that in a sense is the ideal
function
for a for a population in this case of y
and a single x
so let's talk more about this regression
function it's also defined for a vector
x so if x has got three components for
example it's going to be the conditional
expectation of y given the three
particular instances of of the three
components of x
so so if you think about that
um let's think of of x as being two
dimensional because we can think in
three dimensions so let's say x lies
on the table
two-dimensional x and y stands up
vertically
so the idea is the same we want to we've
got a whole continuous cloud of of y's
and x's we go to a particular point x
with two coordinates x1 and x2 and we
say what's a good value for the function
at that point well we're just going to
go up in the slice and average the y's
above that point and we'll do that at
all points
in the plane
we said it's the ideal or optimal
predictor of y with regard
for the function and what that means is
actually it's it's with regard to a loss
function and what it means is that
particular choice of the function f of x
will minimize
the sum of squared errors right which we
write in this fashion
again expected value
of y minus
g of x over all functions g
at each point x right so it minimizes
the average
prediction errors
now
at each point x we're going to make
mistakes because
if we use this function to predict
why
because there's lots of y's at each
point x right and so
the errors that we make we call in this
case we call them epsilons and those are
the irreducible error
you might know the ideal function f but
of course it doesn't make perfect
predictions at each point x so it has to
make some errors but on average it does
well
for any estimate
f hat of x and that's what we tend to do
we tend to put these little
hats
on estimators to show that they've been
estimated from data
and with so f hat of x is an estimate of
f of x
we can expand
the squared prediction error at x into
two pieces
there's the irreducible piece which is
just the variance of the errors
and there's the reducible piece which is
the difference between our estimate f
hat of x
and the true function f of x
okay
and that's a squared component so this
expected prediction error breaks up into
these two pieces
so that's important to bear in mind so
if we want to improve our model
it's this first piece the reducible
piece that we can improve by maybe
changing the way we estimate f of x
okay
so that's all nice this is a kind of as
up to now has been somewhat of a
theoretical exercise well how do we
estimate the function f
so the problem is we can't carry out
this recipe of conditional expectation
or conditional averaging exactly because
at any given x in our data set
we might not have
many points to average we might not have
any points to average in the figure i've
we've got a much smaller data set now
and we've still got the point x equals
four
and if you look there you'll see
carefully that the solid point is one
point i put on the plot the solid the
solid green point
there's actually no data points whose x
value is exactly four
so how can we compute the conditional
expectation or average
well what we can do is relax the idea of
at the point x
to
at in a neighborhood of the point x and
so that's what the notation here refers
to
n of x or script n of x
is a neighborhood of points defined in
some way around the target point which
is this x equals four year
and it keeps the spirit of conditional
expectation it's close to the target
point x
and if we make that neighborhood wide
enough we'll have enough points in the
neighborhood to average and we'll use
their average to estimate the
conditional expectation
so this is called nearest neighbor or
local averaging it's a very it's a very
clever idea it's not my idea it's been
invented long time ago and of course
you'll move this neighborhood you'll
slide this neighborhood along the x-axis
and and as you up as you compute the
averages as you slide in along it'll
trace out a curve
so that's actually a very good estimate
of the of the of the function f it's not
going to be perfect
because
the the the little window it has a
certain width
and and so some as we can see here some
points of the true f may be lower and
some points higher but on average it
does quite well
so we have a pretty powerful tool here
for estimating this conditional
expectation just relax the definition
and compute the
the nearest neighbor average and that
gives us a fairly flexible way of
fitting a function
we'll see
in
in the next section that this doesn't
always work especially as the dimensions
get larger and we'll have to have ways
of dealing with that